We know what a big star you are in the United States, North America.
Is it comparable in all of these other countries?
It's really fun in other countries.
I love the fans there and we get to play arenas and it's really wonderful and,...
...it's interesting because you go over there and they don't speak the same language as you.
So, I always try to sort of, like, adapt myself a little bit by learning a few phrases.
Right!
I think that's a great thing to do.
Sometimes it fails miserably but like,...
...but like when I'm in Japan, like I just speak in Japanese the entire show.
No, you don't.
Yeah.
I don't sing in Japanese, but I speak in Japanese.
You can actually, you're conversant in Japanese to get through like a 90-minute concert in Japan?
Well, I mean, you just memorize them, and then you figure out what it means.
What do you say?
Like you go like,...
Wow!
What did you say?
First I said, "Are you having fun Osaka," then I said, "I love Japan," then I said,...
..."Japan is awesome," and then I said, "cute".
Well.